if you ignore all the Wayne's World
Austin Powers and Shrek movies Mike
Myers entire post SNL resume seems a lot
less shagadelic from So I Married an Ax
Murderer and 54 through the genuinely
horrifying The Cat in the Hat there were
far fewer hits than misses after the
third Austin Powers and a five-year
break from movies Mike Myers re-emerged
in 2008 with the nearly universally
hated comedy The Love Guru which Roger
Ebert called a dreary experience Maya's
Tacoma Razzie and apart from a cameo in
one scene in 2009's in glorious bastards
and a few documentaries he remained
off-screen for years his next major
project was his two season stints
hosting a Gong Show Revival starting in
2017 followed by roles in Bohemian
Rhapsody and terminal the following year
his bad luck continued into 2022 with
his most recent film The Almost
universally panned Amsterdam